in the quiet setting of st. George's
Hall the newest member of the royal
family
Archie Harrison was making his first
public appearance in his father's arms a
beaming Duchess of Sussex telling the
world what it's like to be a new mum
magic it's pretty amazing and I have the
two best guys in the world so I'm really
happy
parenting is amazing it's it's only been
what two and a half days three days yeah
we just we're just so thrilled to have
have our little bundle of joy
dispensing British time to him as he
slowly slowly starts to grow up it was
again on Instagram that they announced
the name archie harrison
mountbatten-windsor and that their son
won't use an official title it came
after an important meeting between the
Queen the Duke of Edinburgh and their
eight the great grandchild Megan's
mother Doria also there to support her
daughter with the name archie harrison
and that small low-key photo opportunity
Harry and Megan have set out the kind of
parents that they want to be a doting
mum and dad who are now going to do
everything they can to give their son as
ordinary and upbringing as possible
grandad Prince Charles and Camilla are
on a visit to Germany at the moment they
were shown the new photos of the
grandson they're still to meet Harry and
Megan may have wanted this to be a small
and intimate occasion for that hasn't
dampened the excitement or the
anticipation about the baby's name I do
think the name is cute and adorable just
to match his little face know what
happens elexander all lovely traditional
names in the states I know my friends
and I we really kind of like idolize or
like enjoy the idea of monarchy so we
prefer those more traditional names I
think when it comes to the royal seas
like any new arrival this has of course
been an important family moment it was
so nice so
to introduce the baby to
this little boy was blissfully unaware
of the fuss Harry and Megan will want to
keep it that way for as long as possible
as they head off the more precious
private time as a family of three
Rhiannon Mills Sky News in Windsor